merci bruno merci d'animer cette table
ronde bienvenue dans le xvème puisque je
ne lis pas je suis maire du 15e même si
ici on s'est un peu frappé
d'extraterritorialité tout cas 15e
évidemment il faut encore the place to
be donc suivre peut-être d'être là pour
parler il ya beaucoup de parisiens dans
la salle de la sécurité plus
particulièrement dans notre ville et
dans notre région aussi puisqu'il y à
une réforme essentielle qui a été
accompli par nicolas sarkozy en matière
de sécurité c'est pas la seule bien sûr
mais c'est une réforme très importante
pour beaucoup de villes en france qui
est la réforme de la police
d'agglomération à paris on appelle ça la
police du grand paris aujourd'hui que
nous sommes dans une autre structure
territoriale la police d'agglomération
c'est tout simplement considéré que la
sécurité doit être appréhendé non pas
ville par ville territoire par
territoire délimité par des limites
administratives mais dans le bassin de
délinquance
ce qui est assez logique à vrai dire
encore faut-il le faire et organiser les
forces de police d'en gérer de
gendarmerie forces de sécurité aussi
municipales et privées de façon à ce que
l'appréhension puisse se faire dans le
bassin de délinquance
pour ce qui concerne le grand paris
puisque la police d'agglo à paris c'est
paris plus les trois départements de la
petite couronne avec des mutualisations
police gendarmerie dans les départements
de la petite couronne
mais là on est un peu dans l'est dans
les périphéries pour ce qui concerne la
police d'agglomération à paris vous quel
est son intérêt
quand je vous dirais que il ya plus d'un
délinquant sur deux par exemple
appréhendé à paris qui n'habite pas
paris mais qui habite dans la banlieue
parisienne dans les trois départements
de la petite couronne et qu'il y a une
vingtaine d'années il y avait plus de
délinquance à paris
ça paraît incroyable aujourd'hui de fait
dire d'une trentaine d'années il avait
plus de délinquance à paris que dans la
petite couronne
aujourd'hui évidemment le phénomène
s'est inversée donc lutter dans la
petite couronne contre la délinquance
c'est lutter à paris contre l'intense et
réciproquement donc il y à là la
nécessité d'organiser les forces de
sécurité par rapport à 7
organisation par rapport à cette
délinquance de l'ensemble du grand paris
avec un commandement unique
un commandement parce qu un commandement
unique c'est toujours plus efficace que
quand il y a plusieurs chefs qui se
disputent donc accords moment unique et
celui du prêt de police
je salue d'ailleurs la présence du
préfet de police qui a presque mis en
oeuvre cette réforme michel gaudin dans
paris et dans l'agglomération c'est lui
qui l'a mis en oeuvre d'ailleurs à
partir du moment où la réforme a été
accomplie donc ce que nous voulons par
rapport à cette police d'agglomération
qui a été étendue dans un certain nombre
si d'agglomération l'agglomération
lyonnaise et quelques autres c'est
qu'ils puissent être ce qu'elles
puissent se développer dans la plupart
des villes en france où on peut
considérer qu'il y à la nécessité
d'appréhender à bassins de délinquance
c'est comme si on disait qu'à paris les
délinquantes passait pas le périph ça
n'a aucun sens eh bien c'est la même
chose dans la plupart des villes où est
ce que veut dire sur la police d'agglo
quelques mots sur la sécurité à paris si
tu le permets d'abord il faut bien dire
une chose c'est que paris vous le savez
la préfecture de police
je pense que le contrôle d'un certain
nombre de responsables policiers
parisiens ici michel gaudin ou eric le
douaron qui était un formidable
directeur de la sécurité publique à
paris et que je salue la plus tôt plus a
été je ne veut froisser personne bien
sûr un peu la vitrine de la police
nationale dans notre pays
et bien aujourd'hui aujourd'hui cette
vitrine est particulièrement ébréché
puisque l'on peut considérer que la
préfecture de police
pour moi c'est ainsi que je la décris
elle n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle-même
malgré les réformes pourtant qui ont été
accomplis sous la mandature précédente
et qui devrait permettre une
amélioration en matière de sécurité à
paris et malgré tout la gestion depuis
deux ans on fait que l'abricot de police
n'est plus du tout le fleuron de la
police nationale qu'elle était autrefois
d'abord un blason qui a été ternie par
les affaires c'est quand même assez rare
qu'un directeur de la police judiciaire
se trouve mis en examen et même
plus que ça c'est assez rare qu'il y ait
des affaires disons criminels comme du
vol de cocaïne dans les services de
lutte contre les stupéfiants tu ou des
viols collectifs à la à la mairie tout
ça en plus avec une mauvaise gestion de
l'ordre public
chacun se souvient de la façon honteuse
dont ont été gérés l'ordre public pour
les manifs pour tous il ya une
commission denquête d'ailleurs qui a été
institué cette cet égard chacun se
souvient aussi de la façon dont la
délinquance est géré dans la capitale
c'est à dire que nous avons aujourd'hui
un peu comme sur le territoire national
d'ailleurs une augmentation de la
délinquance dans à peu près tous les
domaines
les atteintes aux biens les vols simples
et vols à main armée les atteintes aux
personnes les violences physiques non
crapuleuses et une explosion des
violences sexuelles
par dessus le marché la ville de paris
qui est un rôle à jouer en matière de
sécurité notamment budgétaires ou c'est
un budget spécial d'un peu plus de
police qui est abondé en partie par la
ville de paris
et bien pour la première fois depuis
l'an passé d'ailleurs pour la première
fois ce budget est en baisse ce qui
amène la préfecture de police à réduire
aussi l'ampleur de ses moyens et alors
ce qui a inventé la maire de paris pour
le budget 2016 que nous allons bientôt
examiné ma chère brigitte dans la séance
budgétaire du conseil de paris et c'est
que la participation
c'est quand même incroyable la
participation de la ville de paris au
budget de la prime de reprise être
indexé sur un élément on pourrait
imaginer que c'est la hausse ou la
baisse de la délinquance culture du
résultat
pas du tout sur le nombre de pv sur le
nombre de pv mis par les fonctionnaires
à paris c'est la fameuse guerre contre
les automobilistes
c'est assez différent de la guerre
contre la pollution d'ailleurs et bien
aujourd'hui il faut que vous sachiez que
le budget de la préfeture de police va
être indexé à la demande de la mère de
paris sur le nombre de pv inflige aux
grévistes tout ça ne va pas du tout il
faut donc modifier les choses à nous
avons un certain nombre de deux
propositions à faire
tout d'abord il est nécessaire je pense
est d'ailleurs bernard lhez l'a dit tout
à l'heure de bien séparer la sécurité et
de la tranquillité publique et à paris
comme ailleurs c'est que le maire de
paris est le seul à ne pas être officier
de police judiciaire le seul à ne pas
avoir de pouvoir de police et bien faut
que les choses évoluent comme dans
toutes les autres villes on à l'héritage
comme tu disais de bonaparte et de la
révolution enfin aujourd'hui les choses
ont changé sur le plan politique et on
ne craint pas une révolution ou un
putsch par les parisiens pour renverser
l'état
donc il est nécessaire de rétablir les
pouvoirs de police au maire de paris et
que celui ci puisse créer une police
municipale
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
il est nécessaire aussi d'accroître le
développement de la vidéoprotection ont
mis en oeuvre aussi par le gouvernement
précédent bien sûr nous avons un millier
de caméras à part il est nécessaire de
passer à une deuxième étape de 1000
caméras
je rappelle que à londres ses
soixante-quinze mille caméras qui sont
reliés directement à scotland yard
il terminera droit public à paris une
caméra pour 2000 habitants alors qu'à
nice et christian a parlé tout à l'heure
il ya une caméra pour 350 habitants on
en est loin
bien sûr il ya dix mille caméras dans le
métro et dans les réseaux transport mais
là aussi il y à des améliorations à
faire beaucoup de rames de métro ne sont
pas pourvus il ya aussi la nécessité que
la ville de paris équipe son patrimoine
en caméra notamment dans les deux sens
ensemble y est sensible dans les
équipements aussi municipaux stade etc
bref beaucoup de choses à faire pour
améliorer la sécurité à paris merci
merci